[Music]
I have three young kids and I live next
door to someone who went to prison for
incest and sexual misconduct with
minor good I don't even want to open the
door to conversation with him I handle
these things kind of weird I tend to go
directly to it and that's not for
[Music]
everybody what up what up what up this
is John with the Dr John deloney
show it's a Halloween
episode happy Halloween everybody if you
don't celebrate Halloween cool on you if
you do cool on
you and before we get to the uh so hang
on with us to the end of the show
because we got some cool Halloween stuff
at the end here but dude we all have to
celebrate we got to
celebrate building a non- anous life
number one adult non-fiction on the big
boy list on the big boy list which is
Super Rat we are so proud of you dude
that was the whole gang man there
everybody in the club got Tipsy on that
one it was so good dude I'm so happy I
uh yeah man I was on the road and I got
a text message which is how Preston
communicates and it's so great so great
man I'm still kind of in awe so uh got
right off the road and then I got super
super sick and so I'm just now crawling
my way back to life but man I haven't
had a moment even just to cheer and
celebrate but here we are Tada way to go
America dude hey every one of y'all that
listened to me do stupid ad not stupid
ads but do ads for months months thank
you thank you for enduring um building
an unanxious life number one and uh
pretty exciting man pretty pretty
exciting even more cool is when my
daughter saw my face in an airport on
like a digital billboard and I was like
finally am I famous and she goes no dad
then I got a book off like my book was
for sale in one of the airports and I
got it and started signing it and she
lost it she was like you do not write in
books and I was like I'm making it more
valuable and she's like no you're not
she is never going to concede she can't
she can't you'll be like in t on TV or
whatever and she will never concede no
you know what's going to happen I'm
going to go to jail and she's going to
have a picture of my mug shot and she'll
be like talking to me through glass and
she'll be like now you're famous dad now
you're famous dad
je that sounds about right with her I'm
not going to jail I'm too much of a nerd
all right let's go to Louisville
Kentucky and talk to the BB what's up
Barb hello Hi how are you I'm
outstanding how are you I'm okay I'm
okay thank you so much for taking my
call I really appreciate it of course
and I know it's nervous to call you are
doing great okay thank you it is really
awkward hey hey my wife tells me I've
been awkward award for a years so you're
all good I didn't mean you were awkward
I'm so sorry oh listen Barb I'm 100%
awkward there is no doubt about it even
in not awkward situations I make just
regular interactions awkward just like
everyone in the booth is like dude I'm
just trying to tell you hello and I'm
like uh one time yeah just I don't know
man so anyway I'm sorry for being so
awkward so nothing you're going to bring
up is going to make me feel even more
Awkward than I've already made it so
what's up well thank you um so
congratulations find your book I bought
it for my husband and he loves it you're
awesome thank you thank you thank you
nothing says I love you husband like uh
here's a book about anxiety you should
probably read it's true it's a true
story um okay so I I have never talked
about this with anybody so I'm gonna do
my best to get through this without
crying hey feel free to cry away cry
away okay thanks okay so I have been
married for about 12 years and um before
we got married um my husband had told me
that he had had an issue with porn
um a very significant issue uh went back
to um the age of nine uh when he started
it was given to him by his dad um his
mom died
traumatically and that was one of the
ways I guess his dad taught him how to
cope with his pain so they never talked
about the grief and the trauma or
anything he basically just went to
alcohol and gave my husband porn so um
we talked about that before we got
married I was very clear that I just not
the kind of person that can really
handle having that as a part of my
marriage and he agreed he'd gone through
a lot of um healing and like group work
um and therapy to try to work through a
lot of like the reasons behind why he
used horn in the first place so fast
forward about three years um he started
getting a little bit different and I
felt like something was off and so I
confronted him about it and um he was
using erotica at the time um and
masturbating um privately to that and um
around the same time also had like a
significant moment where he became very
suicidal I had to call his therapist I
had to call the police and remove the
guns from our house and have them sent
to the station and um the police showed
up at his work to make sure that he was
safe um so we worked through of that his
therapist worked through that with him
and things got a lot better so fast
forward another uh three years and I had
a similar feeling uh that something was
off
again and this time found out that he
was masturbating again at the time he
was actually using porn but did not
communicate that with me in a way that I
realized that that was going on I
thought it was just
masturbation so we worked through that
uh no suicide or anything at that time
no significant issue of depression and
fast for it again and here we are for
the third time and um this time there's
not porn involved it's just solo
masturbation but I noticed him pulling
away from me and um just not being
present with me and um I'm so sorry no
don't be sorry don't be sorry take your
time and now this time there's you know
the the suicide um thoughts back and the
significant depression and and I am at a
place where I you
know screw me once shame on you screw me
twice shame on me kind of thing now
we're here the third time and I'm having
to carry all of this and I love him and
he's truly a really good person he is a
a nine on the aces score and has a
significant amount of trauma in his
background and he has worked through so
much he is um an amazing father and a
wonderful person and I don't know what
to do like how do I I guess my question
is how do I support him and not become
bitter and take care of myself and not
wonder why does this keep happening
because there must be something wrong
with me yeah why this keeps happening
you know I I am a five on acis um so my
trauma is not as bad as say as far as
like I didn't lose a parent and all that
but I did have significant like child
abuse and sexual abuse we don't we don't
compare trauma on this show trauma is
trauma is trauma is trauma so um all
right so can I hop in here yes please do
okay number one you don't say this out
loud very often do you I've never talked
about this with anybody I'm really proud
of
you
thanks so tell me you're either being
flooded with oh my gosh I can't believe
I said that or you're being flooded with
relief which one is it I feel relief um
there you
go you'll feel guilty later you'll feel
that weird over like over vulnerable
like ah you'll feel that later but right
now I want you to I want you to fully
feel this for one second okay
okay because this is going to be part of
your path
forward okay is you have to stop keeping
secrets from him and from your small
group of people that you trust deeply
okay that's part of that feeling that
you're carrying all of this by yourself
it's too
heavy okay and you're not protecting him
and you're not protecting this image of
a marriage that everybody thinks you
have and honestly you're not protecting
your kid or kids by holding all these
secrets okay
okay so I want you to feel how good this
feels just once to say it to a a
somebody that you know um you don't know
me but you know I'm not going to be mean
to you I'm not gonna be like oh my God
like that's not gonna happen okay yeah
now I'm gonna talk through a couple of
things and I'm going to give you
probably some advice that nobody has
given you yet okay okay and I also want
you to know that it may be a
disaster okay okay cool but when things
are a
disaster I tend to head into them not
away from them okay okay so number one
you started this whole conversation by
telling me that his dad gave him
pornography as away as a in as a form of
a drink when he was a child yeah the
complexity of his trauma is very layered
right mom passes away dad becomes an
alcoholic dad hands him pornography
pornography and masturbation at 9 years
old becomes a self soothing like a way
to disappear from any sort of pain right
yeah how old are your
kids um six8 and 11 God help y'all right
so you have a 6 eight and 11 year old
right so that means you have a fifth
grader a middle schooler and in the
middle somewhere um and every dad feels
um less than every dad feels like they
should something should feel different
they should be more engaged with their
kids not enough working more not working
more
whatever and his body taught him at 9
years old this is how you deal with this
some dads work longer some dads join
fantasy leagues some dads work out too
much some dads dads play video games
some dads what like they just crack
beers on the couch your husband's body
taught him at a young age via his dad
through some gnarly trauma that this is
how we deal with this stuff
okay I tell you that to tell you none of
this is about
you okay my guess is your trauma as a
little girl you learned to solve that
trauma by making sure that everybody was
okay
MH and this one's not about you and
that's
hard
okay here's the second thing for some
reason I to say that this young man has
has put in the work he's put in the work
huh he's put in a lot of work okay yeah
I want to try something that's unique
number one we're not going to screw
around with suicide cidality okay never
ever ever ever ever any hint we're
calling everybody any hint we're calling
everybody
okay
um but it sounds like if I look at
Trends okay and these are multi-year
trends for you it's happening again and
again and for me it is a lifelong
addiction to pornography
masturbation that goes to
just reading it m which goes to had a
miss a mess up not suicidal just just to
now a guy just jerking off in his
bathroom right
yeah on a trend line that's a guy that's
doing a lot of work okay and I don't
have a problem with a guy masturbating
in his
house like that that doesn't tell me
that there's something broken in a
marriage that doesn't tell me anything
okay okay that and so here here's why
I'm telling you that I think the
approach is let's remove the shame from
that particular
act and one of the ways to do that is to
invite yourself into that
moment you see what I'm saying how do I
do that like hey next time you are about
to take masturbate take care of yourself
by yourself can I join you okay I did do
that I did tell her okay tell me about
that how'd that go um fine
I I mean I don't think I mean I think
that's what he's done
since I think did did it demystify it
that's what I'm saying did it dhame
it I don't know I I'm not sure okay for
him you mean did it
yes I don't know if it did or not okay I
think it's worth a follow-up
conversation because there sounds like
again I haven't talked to him it be
completely unrelated but it sounds like
somehow this shame and this loop-de-loop
and this trauma Loop are all wound up
together if these depressive Cycles
follow these patterns right and he ends
up in this dark place
yeah but I think I think the the the
helping part of you is to be curious not
oh my gosh my marriage is falling apart
okay okay you have drawn a hard line of
pornography and I fully agree with that
line and so I think his work is not
Crossing that line because I think
that's very fair that you drew that
boundary I'm proud of you for that okay
okay the second or the third or fourth I
don't know what number we're on um
is me asking you are you
done no I don't get in your voice that
you're done I get in your voice that
you're just so
exhausted I'm tired I'm just really
really I just feel like I can't because
I because of the um suicide feelings I
can't talk about my feelings without him
shutting down so you know what I mean
like yeah he does have a lot of guilt
and I don't I don't know how to navigate
that what are your feelings that he
shuts down
from the shame I think he feels he feels
from what he's told me like he's not a
good husband and that's not true sure
but major depression doesn't tell the
truth and it's just so hard to waade
through right is he is he taking his
meds is he taking care of business on
that front yes and they just started him
on another one okay and when they do
that they off what do they tell you to
watch real closely right yeah they're
adding on like augmenting therapy
instead of switching okay
okay
so I guess the are you seeing somebody
too I don't know I mean I have a
therapist she's $175 an hour and to be
completely honest I love her and she's
amazing but she's so expensive and our
budget you know is tight and I that's a
whole other topic
yeah um is your husband
working um well kind yes and no yes yes
he does work but I've had to go back to
work full-time because of the industry
he's in it's just he's in the mortgage
industry and it's not going well right
now right so um it may be time for him
to change careers
dramatically because he's in an industry
where the best of the best of the best
are really struggling right now yeah
right and if you have a history of
really struggling and then you're
surrounded by people who are
struggling it may be time for that to to
have that conversation see what I'm
saying yeah I think that could be a
really important moment for
yall yeah we've had that conversation a
lot actually um and depression gets on
that Loop and it sticks and it sticks
and it sticks one of the lies of
depression is the way you feel right now
is your fault and it's always going to
feel like this yeah right and so there's
something about shaking the snow globe
and saying let's do something different
let's make a move and let's work on that
together I I get that it's expensive if
your counselor's
wonderful um I think it's worth putting
some money on the
table and even if you give it six more
sessions and I know that feels like a
million dollars with three kids and a
husband who's just not bringing home any
money because there's no deals being
done in his industry right now um he
might find he might find a ton of
purpose and driving Uber in the morning
or in the evenings figuring out some way
to make some extra money
um or you guys sit down and figure out
like hey let's look at other Industries
let's look at you know Bank whatever
else he I don't know what he's qualified
for but
um I think there's something really
valuable in purpose and that stuff it
starts a compound itself like I don't
want to go to work and then you stop
making money and then that depression
gets heavier and there's something about
taking baby steps out of that right out
of
it
um but I think it's worth taking six
sessions on your end and going to your
counselor and saying I need some very
specific guidelines on how to walk
alongside my husband during this season
when he's feeling
low and if you want to invite him into
that conversation I think that would be
wonderful because what you'all need to
do is come up with a few strategies so
that he
knows shame doesn't fly in our house we
don't have secrets nothing to be ashamed
of I'm proud of my husband and I love my
husband he's done a lot of work work
he's inviting me into some very intimate
moments in his life in his life but
beneath that is the sense that hey we
got to get a job we we're making some
money we have to redefine purpose in our
house and I'm with you and so when I
turn the lights on it's not to shame you
it's to invite
you and I think it's bringing that more
and more to the light and so if he'll
come with you on a for a couple of
couple sessions as y'all practice
learning new ways to talk to each other
that's great he's got a pay close
attention to that depression medication
I think that's that sounds like where
he's at right now he's had a rough rough
go of it his whole life and man I'm glad
he lives in a moment of History where he
can get the help and care that he
needs I don't want you to give up on you
all right
Barb I know this is hard to talk about
you've got to find a group of women that
you can sit down and speak with they
don't cost 175 bucks an hour even though
I think coun is counseling is important
right now
call two or three or four women call
them together for coffee and say hey
it's vulnerability time I got to let
y'all know where I'm
at thanks for calling Barb I'm really
grateful for you hang on the line I'm
going to send you a whole bunch of stuff
are you ready I'm going to send you all
the questions for humans couples cards I
want you and your husband to
begin dating again if you will just
having conversations again no pressure
second thing is I'm going to send you my
friend Ken Coleman's book paycheck to
purpose um and I want you and your
husband to read that together the third
thing I'm going to send you is one year
of Financial Peace University in every
dollar okay that's our financial tool
you said it's a whole other call I can
imagine y'all struggling financially too
I'm going to send that to you in the app
y'all can work it together but as you
have conversations about hey honey what
if we we got to get you out of this
industry that's really struggling right
now surrounded by people who are NE
negative negative negative and get you
into a place where you can see the light
again sharing how your money is going to
work together is going to really help
you I'm so grateful that you called and
for being vulnerable call anytime we'll
be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits that almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way hallo
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition or
if you don't have a faith tradition it's
a great place to start from scripture
readings to prayers to journaling hallow
makes it easy to practice mindfulness
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and choose peace remember hallow is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone today to
start your free trial
just follow the simple prompts at
hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we're back let's go out
to Indianapolis and talk to Lisa what's
up Lisa Hi how are you I'm good how are
you I am good I'm hiding in my laundry
room so we're doing great excellent
what's up so I wrote down my question
because I'm a little nervous cool read
it it this what I have for you um I have
three young kids kids and I live next
door to someone who went to prison for
incest and sexual misconduct with a
minor oh oh good yeah I feel my children
are safe as we have an open dialogue
about said neighbor and they know that
anyone from that house is not safe my
issue comes and interacting with that
neighbor um there have been instances
where he said Hi and um I don't even
want to open the door to conversation
with them I also feel my heart take off
anytime I think about who lives next to
me and I don't want to be affected
mentally by this every day in a negative
way how old is your neighbor how old is
my neighbor he's um in his 50s okay
how'd you find out about the details of
his um previous um
incarceration
um so my husbands owned this house like
even before I knew him we lived here we
moved we' moved back into this house and
then when we moved back into this house
I was just I take my kids safety very um
you know serious and I was like I'm just
GNA make sure that no one in town
because we live in a really small town
um nobody in town is dangerous you know
and come to find out he lives right next
door so got my answer um do you know if
he's still under any kind of
supervision uh he's still registered as
a sex offender
okay so the first thing I would do would
be to call and see if you can get the
person he has to check in
with and just say I'm a neighbor with
three small kids okay and if depending
on where you live there may be a
violation because he's not supposed to
be in vicinity of said kids this many
yards away okay um probably that's not
the case but it's worth finding out but
by contacting a
supervisor you might
find that here's the real story okay the
real story
was when he was 26 he whatever or the
real story I know it was like he got out
of prison like within the last 10 years
so right but but it could be that he was
um sexually abusing his daughter yeah it
it could be that he was a cousin right
yeah and so I know it was his daughter
okay okay yeah um and so the second
thing is
I I handle these things kind of weird
okay okay I tend to go directly to it
and that's not for
everybody um if the neighbor waves and
says
hello I'm not one to usually just go
kids look at the ground look at the
ground walk
in I like to go across the street and
say hey I'm so and so we're your
neighbors man I got a report that this
happened and I'm super uncomfortable
with my
kids okay and that's just how I handle
stuff um and not in a threatening way in
any shape form or fashion in a
respectful way um and it might be oh no
nothing but but I mean it's just kind of
calling it out
right the bigger deal is I don't
want there's a fine line between
vigilance and being smart right teaching
your kids
awareness and making them terrified
about a neighbor right and that's a fine
line I the joke is but it's not a joke
my dad was a homicide detective and he
used to put Polaroids of people getting
out of jail on the family
desk and I was a little kid I mean I was
I don't remember how young I was but it
was like Hey if these guys ever get come
come to the door don't answer it and
that was really
helpful and at a really young age I
internalized hey at any moment a killer
can knock on your door right right and
so I still don't like answering my door
and I'm old right like I'm an old man
now so there's a fine line between all
neighbors are scary and
terrifying right and so finding that
sweet balance is really smart um and
then third thing is me just move why
what tell me about this
house um I mean we just moved into it uh
like six months ago and we love it like
we're super happy where we are except
your heart beats out of your chest every
time you walk out the front
door yeah yeah yeah so there's there's a
story that you tell yourself that you
love it but you don't you hate it you're
terrified of it it's like I I'm not
terrified of it I guess like I'm not
scared of him I'm like Angry you know
every go it's like I don't know I like
why can't everyone just love their kids
right you know and like who does that to
their child yes um keep going keep going
keep
going I don't know I
just it just makes me angry when
angry not hold on anger often covers up
grief
yeah how old are your kids uh I have a
six-year-old and then I have twins that
are five okay you thought moving into
your home with your three little ones
and your husband was going to look like
X yeah and it was going to feel like X
and instead it feels like why because
you have a child predator that lives
next door to you right it's grief you're
mad right
yeah I just and like I've tried
to talk to my kids about it in an age
appropriate way because obviously like
I'm not going to tell them like hey this
is who lives NE lives next door and this
is what he did you know I just yeah in a
very like that person is not safe um if
anyone from there ever tries to talk to
you you don't you just come get mommy um
and like that has landed very well with
them they have kids in the neighborhood
that they play with and friends went
over there one day on The Neighbors in
their yard and my kids were like they
came and got me and they're like Mom our
friends are in their yard and I was like
okay thank you they're like we did not
go in the yard you know we they they
they've listened they've comprehended
what I've said sure and I've tried not
to scare them you know because I don't
want them to be afraid let's take it one
step further and not related to that
house at all but I think every family
needs to have a safety plan MH and talk
through good touch and bad touch mhm and
the the parts covered up by a bathing
suit mhm and there's a couple of good
books there's a book um it's a really
thin book you can get on Amazon called
good touch and I forgot the name of the
author we'll link to it in the show
notes here um okay but it's a great
little book just to read to kids um that
shows what's good and what's not good
and play through some fun scenarios
about them being at a park or being in a
next door I mean um not not next door
but being at a park or being at a store
or something like that
and talking through no family like only
person you're allowed to have secrets
with is Mom and Dad any other grown up
you don't have secrets with okay and and
have your sister when she comes over
like hey can I tell you a secret and
have them say no secrets except for Mom
and Dad right okay and we're going to
teach them we're going to teach them a
safety plan a foundation underneath this
thing not just that guy's bad right
right but we're teaching them whole body
positiv we're teaching them autonomy
teaching them to pay attention but we're
doing it in an age appropriate way some
things are private some things only mom
and dad and the doctor can see that's
just the way that goes okay and not in a
you got to cover that up because we
don't want to teach them body shame
either right right their bodies are
amazing they're perfect just as they
were designed and they're
private both both things are true but I
think having those broader conversations
which are way more uncomfortable if
you're not trained
then that guy's bad don't go in that
yard that's the easy way like talking
through the bathing suit conversation
harder right the private parts
conversation and if you or your
husband's ever had any trauma around
those areas that makes those
conversations even
harder and so but I think that's I think
that's where I would start with my kids
with three little ones um and if you're
comfortable if your husband's
comfortable I think kind of addressing
the issue head-on next time the guy's
out in the yard water in the yard or
whatever um in a non-threatening away
just say hey you got 5 minutes you got 2
minutes just say hey man we just moved
in and we got alerted to this is there
anything you want like anything you want
to tell us because I got three little
kids it just makes me nervous right and
he may blow up and then you get all the
answers you need right that's what I'm
afraid of I'm not like a confrontational
person so yeah I mean you just walk away
right I mean if that's if that's the
response my hope would be is that he
would hang his head and say no man I'm I
screwed up 20 years ago I paid my price
never don't you you do not have to worry
about me um but again I'm naive and
super super super optimistic right um
but I think keeping an eye out is wise
but the bigger picture
is if every time you drive into your
driveway your body tenses
up and every time your kids see you
you're looking out the window they will
absorb their home as a place of
tension
and I don't want that for
them and I don't want you to live
constantly Vigilant
247365 I'm all about being vigilant all
the time but there's keeping your eyes
open head on a swivel and then there is
detecting a threat detecting a threat
all the time all the time that begins to
burn a hole through you through your
marriage and through your
kids and so I think the conversation is
worth having hey if I'm not better in a
year in six months I want us to be
honest about this may not be the house
for us with three little ones spending
the next 15 years here next to a
registered sex
offender but I do want to start here
start with see if you can find find his
sponsor we can track down a sponsor and
get a little bit more information a
little more detail that might put you at
peace or it might say nope we're moving
today we are moving right now cuz
sometimes behind closed doors there's
just more to these stories
and well I won't even go there I won't
even go there so give me a buzz back if
I can help in any way we'll be right
back hey delone here good folks our
society has devalued sleep we're told to
keep working and grind through the
fatigue and pretend that we don't need
sleep then this crazy culture tries to
shame us when we do hit the sack at a
normal time I'm here to tell you 7 to9
hours of refreshing sleep is essential
for all aspects of your physical and
mental health and to help with that I
recommend investing in an amazing
mattress getting great sleep is
priceless but a premium mattress can
cost a lot and that's a big reason why I
love dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses
are made with premium materials for half
the cost of other premium mattresses
they use Advanced Technologies to keep
you comfortable all night for a great
price and the exclusive deal they're
offering my listeners can help even more
right now dreamcloud is offering my
listeners 40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 discount go to dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter code John deloney
today that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
code John
deloney all right we are back all right
as you
know number one bestseller building a
non anxious life hit the market it's
been out and it's selling like crazy
it's done so good 100% of that goes to
you guys thank you so so much for that
um we recorded a series that is now
taken off on YouTube and um on this
podcast and so we want to um bring you
the third installment the six daily
choices today's daily choice is one that
you've heard me talk about if you
pre-order the book and you got the
talk it's on this idea of choosing
freedom in a world that has taken every
single Choice from us every single
thought from us even the great Robert
sapowsky the doctor the professor I'm Dr
Robert sapowsky the professor out of
Stanford who has written extensively on
do we even have free will does that even
exist in a world where every single
thought every single action is so
carefully thought
through the great Michael Easter wrote a
new book called scarcity brain where he
talks about how
businesses have just straight hacked our
minds and we wake up and we are anxious
and we are cooked and we are fried and
the bank is telling us what we're going
to do tomorrow and our phones are
telling us to look look look look look
and the processed foods in our pantry
are telling us to eat eat eat eat eat
and the news is telling us who to be mad
at and who to be enraged at and our boss
is screaming at
us this idea of choosing freedom is so
countercultural yet it's so
powerful in our fight to live a
non-anxious life
and so check out this um vignette if you
will I've always wanted to say vignette
actually I've never wanted to say
vignette until just now but this little
vignette um if you're watching on
YouTube check it out if you're listening
to it on podcast you can listen to it
here and I also suggest go to John
delone do or go to YouTube jalone not
john.com YouTube jalone to watch this um
was beautifully shot by Wes and his
team this is the third choice for
building a non- life choosing Freedom
check it
out so the moment your body realizes
that you are not in control and what
comes next in your life it will sound
the anxiety alarms you will be anxious
it has to sound the anxiety alarms cuz
you're not okay this is why you must
choose Freedom if you really want to
build a non-anxious
[Music]
life so here I am the guy that travels
the country telling people about anxiety
and how to live non-anxious lives right
start writing a book and then I start
speaking on stages and then I launch a
little podcast that takes off and then
all of a sudden I started saying yes to
everything even things I didn't want to
do I started telling my kids hold on I
started telling my wife let's look at
next weekend let's look at the weekend
after that I stopped calling my friends
back when they were text and suddenly I
found myself once again chasing titles
and accolades and bank accounts and my
body started slowly sound in the alarms
and it was my wife who one morning came
downstairs and then she said something
that I didn't have a psychology for she
said John we have
enough and that rocked
[Music]
me and there's a part of your brain that
it specific job is to look at problems
and find Solutions look into the future
and say is this a good deal and there's
also a part of your brain designed to
keep you safe you're telling me if we
get fired from our job they're going to
take our cars that we don't own but we
live in a culture that just says why
would you pay cash for a car that's so
dumb you know how nice of a car you can
get and how low you can get that payment
and so Financial Freedom is I will never
borrow money for a depreciating asset
solving for Freedom when it comes to
money means not owing anybody
anything our bodies are designed for
scarcity for not enough and so we fill
our homes up with stuff and we're
scanning all the time and it's never
enough and we get more stuff and more
stuff and instead of our tribal Natures
instead of looking around saying we're
good now we have these little devices
and we're not competing with the Joneses
anymore we're competing with everyone on
planet Earth we can't fit all of our
stuff in our 2,000 3,000 4,000 ft homes
so we have to rent other air conditioned
places to put our stuff into but we look
around and we're suffocating
under stuff under clutter Freedom looks
like asking yourself do I have this
shelf of books because I'm going to read
them or do I have this shelf of books
because I need to announce to the world
whoever comes into my home look how
smart I am look at what I read one time
and if you're looking for inanimate
objects to give you your identity you're
not free what are we doing we're
drowning in
clutter
so I love time and by love time I mean I
love how much I hate time cuz it just
never stops moving and so what do I do I
get a new app I get a new program I read
another book and another book and
another book and I get a new day planner
and most of us live calendars that are
so packed that we can't breathe and we
get mad that the clock keeps spinning
and there's never enough time and we
always want to do this and this and this
and this and we Sprint from one thing to
the next thing to the next thing and
most of us aren't struggling with
alcohol or other addictions that we can
point fingers at most of us are addicted
to busy we're asking our bodies to do
something it wasn't designed to do which
is to go go go go go and so choosing
Freedom when it comes to time is about
taking your calendar and putting it on
your desk and taking your arm and
swiping it across and clearing the whole
thing then you ask yourself this one
question who do we want to be what do we
want it to feel like when we walk into
our front door most people say we want
it to be warm we want there to be
laughter we want there to be a place
where we drop our shoulders and so
choosing Freedom with time means saying
no and that soccer coach doesn't get to
tell you what you do with your weekends
unless you let them and your kids are
great kids and what they really want is
you not another activity so what I'm
asking you to do what I'm asking myself
to do is give ourselves space to be
bored to reflect to think to create to
examine to sit on the stool in between
rounds so that you can get back in the
ring and fight like mad but you have to
create
[Music]
space
boundaries get to be a mess in our
current culture because with social
media with our relationships with our
parents and our in-laws that are just
never ending we don't know where we stop
and where the world begins we are IM
mesed in everybody and everything as of
this recording I have about half a
million friends on Facebook I have about
half a million friends on Instagram and
they write me about what I should be
saying and what I should have said
different L and how dare I and thank
goodness that you're saying whatever it
is you're saying my body is not designed
to take input from a million people I've
never met my body's designed to have a
small Core group of people and we all
agree that this is how we're going to do
life how many of us still let our
in-laws tell us what we're doing for
Christmas how many of us let our boss
determine our selfworth how many of us
say yes to every invitation because the
world revolves around us then without us
the whole world falls down a boundary is
a reverse Golden Rule a boundary is
saying I love others enough and I love
myself enough that I'm going to do what
I need to do to stay whole and well so
that I can go out and serve so I can go
out and love so I can be fully able to
show up when other people are speaking
into your life telling you what you're
going to do and when you're going to do
it and how you're going to do it your
body will sound the alarms because it
recogniz izes you're in the backseat of
your own life somebody else is driving
and so if you want to live a life free
from anxiety you have to choose
[Music]
boundaries the journey starts with
identity and when you begin to identify
who you want to be I want to be a dad
who laughs I want to be a wife who's not
stressed out in running all the time
because I'm someone who chooses Freedom
I'm going to pay off all my debts
I'm getting rid of all the Clutter I'm
putting margin in my calendar I'm making
a short short list of who gets to speak
into my life choosing freedom is about
agency it's about
autonomy it's about you being in the
driver seat of your own life choose
freedom and build a non-anxious
life
hey what's up deloney here listen you
and me and everybody else in the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at john.com
all right we are back that was choosing
freedom and on this day before Halloween
in this Halloween Episode by the way
great job Jenna these
um the beautiful banners these very
maternal banners yes maternal they're
very maternal happy Halloween and
sparkles
exactly it this is awesome I think it's
very clear that I did not decorate the
studio but it looks amazing very cool I
was going to say you get these at eords
but I don't think eard exists anymore
does it no but that used to be that that
think that's a very Texas maybe southern
is because I've said it to other people
and they're like I'm sorry what but
that's where we got everything e yeah I
think it's TVs bought them all yeah all
of our classic Halloween costumes yes
all the like the oh crap it's Halloween
like the night before M would and figure
out what was on sale that's what you got
to be so uh good job for the pumpkin cat
pumpkin C
alternative whatever all right so talk
about scary movies here is uh I'm
talking about two movies that were
transformative for me actually three one
is and then I want to hear from you guys
in the b o so um first one is me and my
friend Tucker we went to the movies and
this is back in the day and for you
young you're going to think this is
crazy there was no Netflix there was no
you had to have HBO that was it um and
or if you were never mind so you had of
HBO and otherwise you went to the movies
and you could call in and it would take
forever or you could look in the
newspaper if you were a thousand years
old or if you're like most of us you
just went to the movies and whatever was
playing you just saw that
movie and so we went to the movies me my
friend Tucker and this movie Scream was
playing and it had Drew Barrymore in it
and we're like whatever let's just
there's no other movies let's watch that
one I was like I heard it
scary that movie was so important
animportant for my development I think I
was maybe in my freshman year of college
Maybe not maybe I was in high school um
maybe I was more through college I I
just remember watching it and spoiler
alert Drew Barrymore is the first person
on the poster like and she's the big
star and she dies in the first five
minutes of the movie and I remember just
going what you can't do that that's the
star and then the whole movie was just
wheels off and I remember thinking to
myself I want that to be how when I do
talks on stages I remember thinking like
Oh I like that I like no one knowing
where we're going to end up and some of
y'all listening to show we're like yep
that's how every show is we don't know
how this thing's going to end but I love
that sense of oh gosh they just killed
off like the lead actress in the first
five minutes now what happens and it
kept me really glued and then okay what
what is you guys scariest movie of all
time actually I have a clip of my
favorite oh you do yes so we're gonna
play it real quick I didn't know you
okay hold let me tell okay I want to
hear your favorite first I want to watch
your clip yes um if you're on podcast
please do yourself a favor and go watch
this on YouTube because it's going to be
well worth your time okay go for
[Music]
it
this whole TV thing not what I
wanted Mr Sheffield Mr completely on
board with this okay so I got a great
new gig hallowen school it's in
marketing it's just for me it's perfect
it's perfect listen the Halloween list
yeah yeah yeah they're real busy right
now and they have the whole zombie
wedding promotion thing going on it's
perfect it's
fantastic have you ever even worked
retail sales before no but how hard do
you
[Music]
she's
actually whatever let's just get her in
here before we have a brial KN down go
all right then tonight just theight old
Jeremiah comes back to the jail and it
his H for
[Music]
murder
it's amazing what people will do it
again into a Halloween
[Music]
store see what you did there uh-huh so
what were you going to
say my scariest movie was not that movie
um it's pretty frightening yeah it's
terrifying yeah would you like to
explain I got cast in a movie called The
Wedding what was the name of it it was
zombie wedding at the Halloween store
something yeah um a friend of mine was
directing a movie and she cast me as one
of the leads and it was a blast we we
would go after work and I would go to a
wedding to like one of those Halloween
stores and we filmed
it
and it's quite chaotic yeah the um there
we can't find the movie itself we've
looked but the trailer is on your IMBD I
don't think I don't know why we were
doing that I think that hurts my
feelings can you send us the whole movie
I don't have it I don't have it yeah we
can't find it anywhere
yeah but that's my my scariest movie
ever good job good job dto
[Laughter]
mine huh what about yours Ben
you know I like uh Stephen King's It
that's that's that's a really good one
for me oh it's fantastic I've read the
whole book and everything it's great no
never seen it worst ever
worst Jenna uh I don't really like scary
movies um but I guess the scariest that
I like it's not really that scary black
phone we watched it last
year it's a psychological Thriller I can
do those I don't do movies like it
scream I could probably do if it's like
cheesy like scary like scary movie the
parody ones I could watch those well
those aren't scary I know okay so the
movie that tripped me out that like so
whenever I'm about to get like in a fist
fight or something gets really scary I
start laughing like I get like a like I
don't know like I get it like a little
giggly and my jaw like my wife says she
could see it coming and she'll grab my
arm and like pull me out of a situation
because she says my jaw is a weird thing
is laying in bed after we went and saw
Paranormal Activity dude oh that is B
saw
I think everybody was freaked out that
that night dude that was like for like
for real CU you lay there and you're
like I I I can't go to sleep nope and
there's so much silence throughout it
the whole movie silence and then there's
just that yeah that one got me dude got
me and Blair Witch Project was pretty
terrifying too oh my God that was the
worst it was so stupid no I watched that
and I was waiting for something to
happen no the way that guy at the end
got me but nothing has touched
paranormal activity for me that one just
that melted me melted me melted
me and uh what's your for real scariest
movie for real scariest movie
um would either be like the Exorcist
that's terrifying phenomenal but
terrifying
um
or well if I was truly something that
was scared me would be it because I'm
terrified of clowns but there's no
chance in in the how you work on this
show I know seriously there's no of me
ever watching it so I don't have to be
scared by it gotcha yeah I mean I have a
t-shirt that said the only good clown is
a dead clown so I'm not a fan that's why
she's on this show she gets needs
therapy herself gez Louise all right hey
if you're not a scary movie person just
don't watch them if you are a scary
movie person make good choices and if
you can happen to find John's movie
Somewhere Out There please
Conta please
yes we love
you I do not love you that's not the
first time you've said that hey be safe
at Halloween love you guys see you
soon